[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland here at coop
Con in Copenhagen Denmark and I'm joined
by Tim Hawken who's gonna give us his
thoughts on a handful of the questions
that you've been asking us this week Tim
you've been around kubernetes a long
time I'm I really like to hear from you
and your words how kubernetes is
changing the course of application
development and ultimately IT operations
at scale sure
I think kubernetes containers and the
sort of orchestration model is really
changing the way people are able to
think about their applications the way
to think about building them and way to
think about running them in terms of
building kubernetes really captures the
micro services model where you could
build lots of small pieces and link them
together into a larger application from
the operations point of view from the IT
side it lets you think about your
applications and your code in a way that
isn't so one-to-one you don't think
about which machine is running which
piece of software and you don't think
about how you handle events and sorts of
things that go wrong and why is that
important it's important because things
go wrong all the time right I mean
everybody who's run an application
understands the reality things crash and
they always crash at two o'clock in the
morning on a Sunday when you are on
vacation right after a night of drinking
right and but with kubernetes that
doesn't happen no it still crash but
kubernetes is designed to accept the
reality that things will crash and we'll
just move it somewhere else because the
the identity of the machine that you're
running on is not that important all
right your application is just a unit
that we can move across the soup of your
cluster and we can just bring it up
somewhere else we can let the system
self heal and if it takes a little while
for that crash machine to come back
online maybe maybe takes a week maybe
you have to buy a new hard drive that's
fine because you shifted the load
somewhere else and once people start to
internalize that idea it changes
fundamentally the way you think about
running your applications in the cluster
this is how we've been doing it at
Google more or less forever
the idea of a machine a VM or a physical
machine a server that runs my
application and just my application is
completely foreign to the sort of Google
mindset of how you build an application
you throw it into the board
and it runs somewhere and so kubernetes
tries to bring sort of the best of that
to the open source world so Tim you've
been around this technology for a long
time you've seen the evolution of Borg
at Google and in its early inception and
its migration into kubernetes how did
how did Google developers make that
transition to writing for Borg and how
does that translate to third-party
developers writing for a kubernetes that
maybe has nothing to do with with that
they're quite detached from the
kubernetes that's ultimately going to
run their application so you know with
Google and Googlers it was back in 2003
ish when Borg started to come into
fruition and in a really a very
different system then than it is now
but the ideas were the same take a
machine share it across multiple users
put some isolation barriers in place so
that you can provide some level of
guarantee that you won't hurt each other
that you can coexist and it took a long
time for people to sort of give up the
private machine mentality especially for
these big applications like search where
you know Google really makes its money
those were very difficult they have very
strong requirements in terms of
performance and guarantees and so it
took a long time for those apps to sort
of come into the Borg ecosystem but once
they did their lives are better for it
right and we think at the consistent
operations the consistent tooling you
know we have a very small cluster sorry
a very small team of cluster
administrators who run the entire Google
fleet and it's amazing because the power
of Borg lets them scale that way so for
people outside Google people who are in
the real world they look at kubernetes
and they see it sort of as this new
thing they don't really know what to
make of it it's natural that people have
some amount of reluctance sure I didn't
do it but the more we show people the
better off they'll be I had a great
personal moment when I was presenting at
using Excel ISA a couple years ago right
room full of systems and excitement yeah
and and I showed them some of what
communities can do it just here's how
you do a rolling update here's how you
do a deployment here's how flip a
service from A to B and there were
audible gasps in the real people how did
you do that
and that was great for me because it's
like this is this is the mindset I've
seen that too the developers who come
around and come to understand how much
kubernetes does for them so that
they can focus on simply their
application packages as a container
instead of that that scaled out I think
it helps take you mentioned it helps
taken a small IT team and turn it you
know functional at larger scale and
smaller but it also helps one developer
team of developers create quite a bit
quite a bit more technology sure you
don't need to have a huge operations
team to run a big fleet and I think you
can get away with a very small ops team
if you've got a small fleet you know
you've got if you got a hundred nodes in
your fleet which is a pretty decent
sized compute fleet right you can run a
pretty big website on 100 machines you
can really run that with one or two
people yeah so you've seen Google
effectively democratized that technology
and make that generally available to
practically anyone absolutely I mean a
big part of kubernetes was bringing
these ideas forward but not just the
ideas on their own like a working
implementation it was really important
for us to say not only do we believe you
should operate like this but we're going
to help you do this right all right now
you've got a position in the community
that enables you to see a lot of the
different hard technical problems around
kubernetes can you give us a sense of
where some of the some of the areas are
that need the most work and I'm talking
less code writing and more like design
decisions some of the big hard problems
sure um you know kubernetes is a big
project it's got a lot of surface area
one of the big problems we have is how
to limit the growth of that surface area
we can't grow forever and so ton of work
has been going into things like
extension mechanisms and plugins and and
hooks and making those things really
truly usable for production-grade
deployments not just prototypes and so a
ton of work has been going in a ton more
work has to be done and is being done
now the community is amazing and very
vibrant here so this is one that I think
is really interesting another is in the
growth of the surface area you see a lot
of new challenges that were not in scope
when we started well you know I work in
the infrastructure side of things so
networking and storage so one example
here is kubernetes growing to fill more
networking spaces things that have
traditionally been filled by
classical virtualized networking in fes
and virtual firewalls and deep packet
inspection and all those sorts of things
that a lot of enterprises a lot of big
companies have done have been have been
sold that they believe in the technology
they value that it brings to their
company how do you map that to
kubernetes yeah and you know this is a
place where kubernetes has to plug into
the way the enterprise already operates
it can't just wipe the slate clean some
of it some of that and some of it is
really looking at the problem with fresh
eyes and coming back to it and saying
how what would be the kubernetes way of
describing this I'm saying right yeah so
there's gonna be some blending there
these are problems that Google never had
right this is a place where or just
doesn't have anything because it's not a
problem that Google deals with right
what are some of the projects that you
find most interesting or some of the
interesting innovations and developments
are happening I'm a big fan of the
estilo project and not just because it
partly comes out of Google but I think
the technology is really interesting
really exciting the the demonstrations
that they can sort of show you like look
we can do this for you is on the level
of the first demonstrations of
kubernetes saying look we can do this
for you right so it sort of gives me
that the childlike Glee when I see
somebody doing something really cool
there are so many other projects I
mentioned earlier the you know
networking and devices there's these all
the work around ml and GPUs that is
happening I think it's really exciting
stuff it's a really hot space that's
gonna really change the world and
probably obsolete me and it's exciting
to see these people working on things
but you know we gotta we gotta figure
out the sort of principled models with
which one seems to be a good fit so far
with kubernetes yeah it seems I can't
imagine it not being a fit but there's
you know previous decisions that we have
to work through in terms of
compatibility and in terms of how do we
fit these things in the system right
right and then who do you find some of
the most inspiring people around the
community the most inspiring people I'm
an engineer through and through so you
know I really look up to folks like
Clayton Clayton Coleman from Red Hat who
is really so fundamental to the project
the project would not be what it is
without him and his team of awesome
people that they brought to the project
but I also look around at some of the
people I work with at Google and but I
measure myself against these guys like
Brian grant who is just a genius and
aratoon who is just the best engineer
I've ever worked with these people are
amazing to me and then you look around
the rest of the space and there's all of
these brilliant exciting people who are
out talking about committees and
evangelizing and showing neat ideas and
you know they don't need to be core
contributors to be really exciting yeah
it's hard to pick any one I tend to be
you know because the people I interact
with the most but there's so many
vibrant community from that so many
people I'm gonna spend all week at cube
con just talking to people I doubt if
I'm a bit of a single talk and then do
you have any advice for maybe a
university student or a young engineer
just getting started with kubernetes how
how do they take that first first step
how do you how do you take a first step
into any open source project you just
start you just decide you're gonna do it
you decide a problem that you want to
try to work on and you start reading
code and then as long as the first can't
clone exactly and if you can start from
main and if you can start reading code
and comprehending it and you go an hour
and you don't find something you need to
fix you're really not looking hard
enough I like it and then finally a
question we were asking all of our
interviewees here how did this is at the
Stifel a little bit of a laugh how did
you get started with kubernetes
so I was working on the Borg team at
Google specifically I was working on the
the node side of the board team and
Omega working on the node agent so the
equivalent of cubelet in the omega side
was called a home light and we were
working on this and we were asked to
work more closely with a cloud team to
see if we could find ways to synergize
to not duplicate work so much and at the
same time this docker thing landed
people started talking about docker and
we looked at it and said wow this is
this is kind of neat it's sort of what
we've got going on inside Mahomet
portlet I could sort of see how this
could turn into an open-source board
which is something that we had sort of
pitched to our leadership before but we
didn't really have the momentum behind
it
and then a few folks at Google took this
and ran with a prototype and they showed
us the this very simple mock-up that
they tore together and it wasn't it was
amazing it was immediate like I see this
I get it this is this is something and
so the opportunity to work on this was
there and I said I would like to help
take this from from prototype into
reality
cool so and the whole wanting in an
omelet I don't know why all right
thanks Tim I appreciate it appreciate
your time here Thanks
you